you
hi everyone is Gerry July 3rd 2015 there
was a spectacular game of chess that was
played in a mortal game a game played
between China's wayyy
playing on the white end against Cuba's
Lazaro zone this was held in danzel
China a sixth annual tournament that was
played there a 10 player round-robin
event and this is a game that's a very
very high caliber game a game that's up
there with Kasparov vs - Paulo of 1999
the game in the century burn versus
Fischer esmad Nobbs immortal these are
the games that kind of come to mind for
me they're not the only ones just
throwing a few out there but it's that
high-caliber game it's something that's
really special it just happened
July 3rd I'm recording this on July 4th
you may hear some fireworks in the
background as I cover this video or
cover this game if you don't at the very
least you will see some fireworks on
board let's have a look game opens with
e4 we have a Sicilian and for the most
part these first 15 moves off and is
skip right through them or zip right
through them we'll get right into the
action soon enough in this open Sicilian
this classical is Kevin again all pieces
getting mobilized bishops out knights
out both sides are getting castled black
making sure the knight does not kick get
kicked away white will do similar with
their knight on c3 soon enough King h1
prophylactic move getting off of the
diagonal the open diagonal Queen e1
shifting over towards the King side g3
h3 more aggressive posts Knight takes
Bishop takes preparing to now fianchetto
queen g3 Bishop b7 some pressure on e4
white stabilizes the knight this pawn is
immune from capture due to the threat on
g7 this Knight is not really an attacker
of the pawn in other words a couple
rooks get involved the bishop is now
optimal on the d3 square
I'm H 7 indirectly queen d8 queen h3 and
what to do now as black how to defend
against these ideas of maybe e5
capturing the night opening up this
diagonal looking for made on h7 black
needs to proceed with caution clearly
there are a lot of aggressive pieces
here these rooks are just waiting for
one of these two pawns to make a capture
so that they can be mobilized that much
more we want an opening up of the
position and open file half open file
the Brooks wants something more to work
with so one of these two pawns will be
moving in short order in the game we had
g6 not the only move interesting one as
I was preparing for this that popped up
on the computer is was rook to e8 it
seems a little bit crazy is e5 working
well maybe not maybe not because of
something like this with rook takes
Bishop pawn takes Knight looks like
we're ready for mate but the bishop
recaptures and we're seeing the point of
that rook to e8 move it's vacating FA
for the king and this Bishop recapture
is vacating a further Square on e7 for
the King to run to in case of Queen
takes h7 and queen to h8 in the game
however instead of a p8 we're having g6
we're still following theory keep in
mind that this has been seen before I
will point out where we have the first
novelty f5 is on board engaging with the
black side there will be some capture
the F pawn will make a capture the F
file will be peeled open soon enough be
5 Bishop back rook to e8 this now gives
white a window of opportunity white is
able to now strike the iron is hot white
is extremely black is vulnerable due to
their last move how can we take
advantage of that on the white side as
the follow-up F takes G H takes and now
Knight to d5
this is the first new move of the
position what is this looking to do it's
looking to eliminate blacks best piece
the knight on f6 it's the best piece
because it's the best defensive piece in
black needs a lot of defense trying to
remove this guy Knight takes Knight if
Bishop takes we can have pawn takes it's
difficult to find a good move for black
at this stage one of the moves with the
computer is pointing out is rook b7 that
can then follow Queen f3 pressure on f7
something difficult to defend and don't
forget about the jeep on who can help
dislodge the knight from F 6 White has
all of their pieces working bishops
rooks Queen and the Jeep on can have a
say in the position looking to again
dislodge that strong knight on f6 in the
game however was not Bishop takes Knight
but instead Knight takes Knight and of
course we recapture that's what we're
used to doing
that's the knee-jerk reaction but we
don't have that here instead rook takes
f7 not caring to recapture the piece
White got exactly what he wanted with
the Knight d5 move which is to remove
the night from the f6 we're not remove
the knife from the board just remove the
knight from the F 6 square clearing the
way for the sacrifice on f7 the weakened
square as a result of that rook e8 move
not much you can do but take the rook
Queen h7 is the mate King takes rook
Queen h7 King e6 he's getting walked
towards the center what else is there
King here that's a quick million one
King is getting pulled right towards the
center pulled even more towards the
center with pawn takes Knight King takes
pawn on Bishop takes pawn they would
follow Bishop takes g6 and there's just
too many threats Queen check Bishop
check don't forget about h3 either there
isn't a good defense in this position
instead King takes pawn and now what to
do the king is ready to escape to c6 and
once he's there you're not stopping him
from getting to c7 and there's no
further attack
what do you do is white invest some more
material a full piece in this case to
accomplish what exactly to lure the king
closer to the center which gives white
time to get the Queen involved King
takes bishop and this is part of what
makes this game so special right here
what we just saw was a bunch of material
invested with those last few moves and
now all of a sudden something quiet
clean this Queen to f7 it's not a move
that captures anything it's not a move
that gives a direct check but it's one
of those silent but deadly moves one
that is threatening in this position
white is threatening six different
checkmates Queen f3 and several Bishop
moves all of which are going to be
discovered checks any of these threes
and excuse me any of these five squares
would be checkmate there's only one way
you can prevent that Bishop f6 and we
have a couple a little bit of a
repetition here with Bishop discovery
giving a discovery King defore Bishop
back and now white comes up with yet
another silent move Queen b3 but again
still throwing a great punch in this
case here Queen d3 is now threatened
there's only one way you can stop Queen
to d3 mate and that is to run with your
King King f5 rook f1 King g4 Queen d3
again another silent move threatening
this time Queen d1 or Queen to e2 and
mate is very soon to follow with white
controlling these two diagonals here
what's tried is Bishop takes g2
investing some material trying to make
the White King a little bit vulnerable
hoping for some defense but there is no
defense there hasn't been a defense
since rook takes f7 Bishop takes g2 just
pointing out one other try if Bishop
here just to emphasize these diagonals
right here we would have Queen d1 check
or Queen e2 king h4
Bishop f2 mate what was tried as Bishop
takes g2 King takes the Queen is now
giving the check King g1 Bishop g5
preparing to run away in this direction
but there's no time
Queen e2 King h4 bishop f2 King g3 or
excuse me King h3 what a walk this King
has had so far if we map that out
Bishop II one is the final move of the
game one other yet another I should say
silent move in this one is the one that
makes black bend this is the one that
made black resign right here what is the
threat exactly rook f3 and there's not
going to be a way to stop that
successfully for example rook here we
can in fact just take that rook on Queen
takes rook Queen g2 is mate there's not
a successful defense against this idea
of rook to f3 in this position what an
amazing game again it's at this point
that black resigns an amazing King walk
a fantastic attack this idea of dropping
the knight in there and not even
recapturing just having him cleared up
clear out of there to sacrifice on f7
luring the King away this is worth
another look just zipping right to that
critical point right here
sacrificing on f7 excuse me first with
this Knight d5 the first novelty Knight
takes not even recapturing just smashing
through King Wat getting pulled towards
the center investing that piece right
here and then a moment of pause right
here that silent move threatening all
sorts of mates Bishop moves with me
Queen f3 with mate it's the only stop to
it we repeat a little bit and then the
Queen with some more silent moves but
all the time throwing these mate and one
or two mate or one making one or two
move combinations and it was just too
much an amazing game feel free to leave
any comments to this video it's really
up there high quality game
I enjoyed covering it I hope you enjoyed
watching it again feel free to leave any
comments in the comment section below to
this video and as always I hope you
enjoyed it that's all for now take care
bye
you